in Moscow this morning Russian President
Vladimir Putin signed the papers
annexing four provinces in eastern
Ukraine in violation of international
law while he was doing that Ukraine's
Army was pushing back Russian forces and
regaining control of some of that
territory Charlie dagada is traveling to
the capture city of Lehman and sent this
report a short time ago
[Music]
the long way because a lot of this
territory is course well within reach of
Russian Firepower the first images have
started to emerge from the embattled
city everywhere there are signs of the
Ferocious battle that took place
delivering the city convoys of bombed
out equals Russian military vehicles are
the belongings of Russian soldiers who
either died trying to hold that ground
they also left behind the bodies of
Russian soldiers on the street which
indicates how quickly they had to
retreat now we spoke to a current along
the way here we asked him why in the
Ukraine has been so successful in his
region in liberating leaving in other
cities he said a lot of it's down to U.S
applied Weaponry the artillery that
they're getting he specifically
mentioned High Mars that have been part
of this battle there have been a number
of explosions here this morning but the
front line has moved on past William now
we're deep inside the Don bass region in
eastern Ukraine this is a very territory
that President Putin claimed for his own
last Friday when he annexed these
territories saying this is now Russian
soil but I can tell you this is owned by
the ukrainians this is a war that's
being fought on momentum and when it
comes down to momentum clearly on the
side of the Ukrainian military
that was Charlie dagada reporting from
Ukraine